so on Monday the Russo brothers as a
joke decided to change their cover photo
on Facebook to a fan-made poster of
Hawkeye this is kind of funny because if
you've noticed a guy isn't in any of the
infinity war trailers or in any of the
infinity war posters but does this joke
buy the Russo brothers actually means
something more than it seems we've
literally seen nothing of Hawkeye's
since Captain America Civil War but he
is listed on the cast for Avengers
infinity war and for Avengers 4 it has
also been rumored that he has been seen
on set many times during filming so
while the secrecy concerning Hawkeye as
it turns out revealing him in trailers
or posters could be a big spoiler to
Avengers infinity war from here on out
I'm going to be talking about some
theories that could contain some
potential spoilers for Avengers infinity
war so here's your official spoiler
alert there's been a lot of rumors going
around concerning Hawkeye so here are my
thoughts and theories on him
my theory Hawkeye will take on the
character Ronan and Avengers infinity
war and Avengers 4 means Jack to me
in the comics Hawkeye actually dies and
is then later brought back to life by
Scarlet Witch
at this point Captain America is dead an
Ironman asked Hawkeye to come back to
take Captain America's place
Hawkeye ultimately declines believing it
is wrong to take Captain America's place
but wants to continue to fight believing
that it's what Captain America would do
he agrees to come back but having dealt
with so much tragedy ditches his Hawkeye
persona and takes on the character Ronan
Clint Barton remains running for a very
long time in the comics until eventually
he gives up the suit the only difference
between Hawkeye and Ronan is Ronan gives
up the bow and arrows for swords and
nunchucks so why do we think Hawkeye
will take on this character Ronan and
how will it happen besides the fact that
it would pretty much follow the same
storyline as after the Civil War comics
we've received this behind-the-scenes
photo of Jeremy Renner and a new costume
most of the costume is covered up but if
you take a look at the boots that he's
wearing they look exactly like the boots
that the Marvel character Ronan wears
this explains half of the reason that
Marvel wants to keep Hawkeye out of the
posters and movie trailers it would
reveal his new character Ronan but
actually more importantly it might
reveal some tragedy that may take place
in Avengers infinity war
Hawkeye only becomes Ronan in the comics
after he dies and is brought back to
life and after Captain America dies it's
widely speculated that many of our
favorite Avengers will die in Avengers
infinity war and Avengers 4 amongst
those it's widely believed that Captain
America and Hawkeye will be among those
it's possible that they both died
Avengers infinity war and for some
reason Scarlet Witch chooses to revive a
guy who's really good at shooting arrows
over Captain America
it's also possible
Marvel directors would get a little bit
away from the comic storyline as they've
been known to do in the MCU but it seems
to be that there will have to be some
sort of huge tragedy in Hawkeyes life
for him to change characters into Ronan
so let's be honest
what does Hawkeye have that no other
avenger has an Avengers age of Ultron
everyone was super surprised to find out
that Hawkeye had a beautiful loving
family that nobody knew about yeah
they're probably gonna die in infinity
war this will give Hawkeye the tragedy
and the motivation to take on the
character Ronan and try to defeat Thanos
not to mention Disney did not want that
scene of Barton's family in age of
Ultron but Josh Whedon fought them until
they allowed it is it possible that
Marvel Studios knew that far in advance
that Hawkeye would be taking on the
character Ronan and the reason it stayed
in the movie was to set up the tragedy
for Hawkeye and Avengers infinity war
what do you guys think this Hawkeye's
family safe is Captain America safe is
Hawkeye safe or is no one safe but Korg
piss off Thanos let me know what you
think in the comments below please be
sure to drop a like and don't forget to
subscribe and follow me on Twitter thank
you so much for watching woof woof